Your comfort zone isn't keeping you
safe. It's slowly killing your
potential. We'll spend hours researching
the perfect workout routine, but won't
spend 30 minutes actually doing
something that scares us. That's not
comfort. That's avoidance. Here's what
nobody tells you. Your brain can't tell
the difference between a saber-tooth
tiger and a difficult conversation
treats public speaking the same way it
treats an actual predator. But here's
the real breakthrough. Discomfort is
just growth trying to happen. Every
skill you value required pushing through
discomfort first. Walking, riding a
bike, having meaningful relationships,
all happened outside your comfort zone.
The most successful people aren't those
who avoid hard things. They're the ones
who made friends with discomfort. Want
to discover how doing hard things can
transform your life? Watch the full
video to learn the antifragile advantage
and become someone who gains strength
from stress, not someone destroyed by